[Music]
I can use a different way Emma Stone
plays a struggling actress in la-la-land
and 28 year old star tells Rolling Stone
the real-life movie industry has come
with a few hardships of its own quote in
the past making a movie II I've been
told that I'm hindering the process by
bringing up an opinion or an idea there
have been times when I've improvised
they've laughed at my joke and then
given it to my male co-star like a pipe
dream Emma also reveals that she was a
seriously nervous kid she credits
therapy and performing for helping her
overcome and cope this is the dream its
conflict and it's compromise it's very
very excited earlier this year
i'muh opened up to ET about one of the
craziest audition experiences she had
early on the casting director wouldn't
let me have we called me sighs there's
reading this monologue and she was like
why are you reading off the paper I was
like because I just received the paper
and she really screamed and then I ended
crying
[Music]